one thing I want to talk about for we're
getting all this this news is the idea
and you talked about this justice versus
equality is very important I think a lot
of people don't know just justice versus
fairness justice versus fairness because
Bernie Sanders now a lot of people don't
realize he's picking up a lot of steam
he's gaining a lot of ground on Hillary
is it likely that he wins no but he is
doing far far better than anybody
predicted and that's on this promise of
fairness and distribution and getting
your fair share people in our generation
really seem to place and if you look at
the Pew Research polls place an emphasis
on fairness fairness and justice aren't
really the same thing you know we talked
about this as a Christian God is just
but life isn't fair and logical so what
do you mean by that listen I certainly
think that as a society it is much more
it was not much more important it's
pivotal that we place importance on
justice not fairness certainly not
fairness of outcomes
that's what leftists believe in
promising let me give you an example of
justice versus equality you're laughing
because you know I know I know I was a
kid in great in french-canadian school
okay this is a true story and this is
where I learned as a kid that fairness
is is in political correctness is just
it corrodes the soul mature like I who
was my teacher must have been blessed
second grade and my dad worked for a
company called a Desa I don't they did
something with cars and one of the
things that he I have these nice pens
eat a bunch of pens Edessa and my dad's
name was on the Pens so he opened up my
desk in my class and I had a bunch of
Edessa pens and it said you know Darren
Crowder so I had those and there was
this kid I don't know I don't want to
name names Daniel cufflink we became
friends later on and he stole my pens
he took my pens as well where are my
pens and then I look over lo and behold
Daniel cufflink is writing with a pen
with my dad's name on it I go hey that's
my pen no I said come on it's clearly my
pen my dad's name it that does your dad
work for an American company a DES is
your dad's last name Crowder and we got
into a fight over it we were yelling is
collided it probably a little too
quickly that's just how I was and the
teacher comes in and says what's going
on in Yale says well he's yelling and
saying that I stole
and I said he did steal my pen and
teacher goes well who is telling the
truth I said I am telling the truth my
dad's name is on that pen there's five
more pens that I have with my dad's name
on that pen you can find them in his
desk and the teacher goes can you to
work this out with with your words
without fighting and I told the teacher
I said I don't need I don't need to work
this out it's not my it's your job as to
is to make sure that people stop
stealing pens I don't know if you notice
it's a problem here in your classroom
broken window theory let's fix the pens
before everyone starts getting their
pens stolen teacher goes well if you
can't work this out with words nobody
gets the pens and took them away they
had my dad's name on the pen and is that
my dad's company
they were clearly stolen pens and the
teacher said well well if you can't work
it out what's fair is nobody gets the
pen
now that was fairness but that was not
justice and what is that what does that
tell you right it places a lot more
burden on the person who's telling the
truth on the person who's not breaking
the law when you're doing whether it's
someone abusing welfare tweeting
bitching about how they need their fair
share from their smartphone while they
have welfare by the way if you're on
welfare okay if you're a bullet and
you're using it in your tweeting for you
you should be put on mute I don't care
what you have to say your bitching is
irrelevant what does it do all Daniel
needed to say is well it's my pen too
because he knew it was a lie and he knew
it didn't matter at that point burden of
proof was even though he knew I was
telling the truth that's what that
favors when you just talk about fairness
and feelings and making sure that
everybody leaves feeling good the
successful person the person who didn't
commit the wrong ends up getting screwed
this is a perfect example
it was my pen that was stolen from my
desk kid took it teacher saw my dad's
name in the pennants in the name of
fairness no one gets the pen
that's fairness that's left ISM that's
not justice and that's something that
Millennials need to understand that's
something that anyone out there needs to
understand fairness and justice are not
the same thing and when you play
identity politics and you play fairness
and you talk about fair share and you
throw it out without defining it it
inevitably favors the person who's
willing to gain the system they're
perfectly fine with screwing the other
guy as long
as they gain from it and I still never
got that pen back hey you're still here
that's surprising I'm not going to lie
this is the Internet most people have an
attention span of four seconds but this
is a clip taken from the full weekly
videocast podcast you can click below to
watch that full video cast or subscribe
on iTunes or SoundCloud click my face to
get a lotta with credit com where there
are more articles and you could read in
a lifetime or click below me where
there's another video it's shorter
because I know you're busy and you have
things to do like find pants